let me ask you this
i think maybe this answer's really
obvious but i don't think i've ever
asked you
every reporter and everyone in media
we've met
is on twitter and they're on it a lot
right they are the twitter twitter
is
the sports gambling
for
journalists yes
[Laughter]
if you're on twitter you're gambling in
likes people you're gambling in
retweets on twitter in order to get good
at you have to just have takes it's just
takes and takes don't have room for
nuance because it's a short piece so
they're just like
what about that what about that and you
shouldn't do this you should do this
right it's that over and over and over
and it drives us to this like black or
white situation
and i just feel like we see it now in
the mainstream media that's out of
that's off of social media you see it in
the times you see in the post you see it
on tv right so much of mainstream media
coverage
is
like get a load of this person and let's
look down on them or shame them can you
believe that or cast them as immoral or
problematic right i think i just
summarized
what like sixty percent of media
coverage yeah
and joe has given millions of americans
another outlet for that
and
a million i mean others other content
creators have followed suit with joe
because they know there's this massive
hole in the market but my question is
like capitalism seems to be pro
misinformation it's pro any information
as long as someone's willing to click it
i'm curious your thoughts on well
capitalism is pro the splintering
of the american consciousness and the
splintering of the media landscape
that's where
capitalism is going to lead us
especially in this era because
so if you rewind
30 years or what not and let's say i had
some batshit ideas um like how would i
get attention to them quite difficult
yeah you know like i i i could like
write a letter to the editor that they
would ignore
i could
um
know like put up some bulletin board uh
leaflets i could stand in the town
square with a sandwich board you know
it's like it
it's tricky for me to gather together an
audience for my
insanity
um now
i don't need much you know i just need a
camera and a bit of a personality and
then i can put something out
and so
whatever point of view you put out there
there's going to be a market demand for
an alternative to it
because people especially in an era by
the way of collapsing institutional
trust where it's like what are they
telling me
that like that can't be right
like oh this person this person's here
to tell me why they're full of
right um so there's there's going to be
this
massive demand for
uh like a different unvarnished point of
view unfortunately a lot of that stuff
is going to be in opposition to the
stuff um that came before which is which
is something that's interesting about
like a dynamic that even you and i share
so
like i just listed a bunch of facts
about the decline of american men right
um and that somehow gets cast as
ideological even though all that stuff
it's just numbers this is numbers you
can look it up and be like this and that
but one of the reasons why it
became uh really popular and interesting
is because people sense that it's in
opposition to the mainstream media
narrative which is not talking about the
collapse of american men because that's
off of their
chosen direction like that their chosen
direction is spotlight uh various
marginalized groups or men are the
problem because they are in positions of
power and therefore you must yeah
there's a zero sum it's like oh in order
for other people to succeed other people
have to fail so so one of the reasons
why it took off is because it's in
opposition to the conventional
media right narrative correct so that if
you have this conventional narrative and
then you're going to have this massive
demand for what's left unsaid
and then there's going to be a whole set
of people that fill it attract an
audience this may be why people are so
eager to
uh
try to prevent any of this crew from
getting a degree of institutional
credibility
because they can look at it and say well
sure your audience may be an enormous
joe rogan but you don't have the
legitimacy of this msnbc contributor
because they're on cable tv and we would
never let you on right
what i don't understand is these
institutions are dying right by the
numbers right um cnn msnbc even fox
but they're still around and they're
still driving our culture is capitalism
going to crush them or are they still
kind of
buoyed by
other forms of american life to keep
them in the game you know like does joe
rogan become cnn like what uh i was
thinking about why these cable news
channels have such power and currency
yeah and a lot of it is that they're
they're very very lucrative they're very
very profitable
uh to the two to hundreds of millions of
dollars a year so if you get knighted by
one of them uh they pay you
uh and
there are so many media figures who are
looking at it being like wait a minute
like if i end up on air with one of
these networks they'll give me six
figures for a part-time job and that's
one of the sweetest gigs uh so so all of
the various folks in this universe want
to be knighted
by uh the the cable networks there's
also a lot of vanity and i will say the
production values are very very high
where uh you know they make they make me
look good to make anyone look good where
like you go on there and they like oh
yeah they like make you up and put you
on the studio and the rest of it like
they build up the republican candidates
for fox news is very intentional about
you know you get more air time in there
your polls start rising you can contend
for presidency or whatever it is and
their audience is the sweet spot of
primary electorate voters they vote
because they're in their 50s and 60s and
if you look at who's voting in these
primaries it's those folks no they're
older than that but yeah the average
viewer of cnn is 59 the average fox
viewer is 65. part of it too is that the
production values are higher so that if
you even see an online clip
of them
like it just looks good yeah it just
seems more legit the people have makeup
on the studios are nice
uh it's one reason why crystal and sagar
they talked to me about their set on the
hill which is that if you had a video
clip of that and it got sent to
someone's parents they would look at it
and think it was legitimate because it
looked like it might have been on on
correct and that was a thing when we
were running for president 2020
legitimization was a big thing right
like getting and they control that for
sure um and it's because there's a lot
of money and influence and
frankly production value behind it but
anyway i feel
like we're just at the beginning of like
i i don't see it end in sight for more
more and more um
joe rogan polarization if you will and
spotify might be the vehicles my
prediction is
something else going to happen on joe's
podcast that when it's sound clipped and
when it's a short clip it's going to be
super objectionable and it'll be a big
artist that's like i'm pulling off
spotify
and maybe spotify has a decision to make
maybe it's a no-brainer but it then
politicizes i'm we're i'm worried about
politicizing our artists and our music
you know
over something that i don't think is
that controversial which is long
conversations with pretty much anybody
he'll take anybody who's interesting i
don't know if you think that's ever
going to happen or if it's just going to
be noise
i'm not sure that there's going to be an
issue that's quite as
freighted and fraught as kovid
you know like i have a hard time
imagining what else you could do that
would
be
as objectionable as your world oh just
wait man there'll be a new big boogie
man in a couple of years i'm sure yeah
maybe yeah i don't know i mean like it's
less yeah if we're more and more like
irrational then it will take less to do
it but oh that that yeah that will
happen that's probably true
oy vey man um good for spotify for
pulling out um for holding strong i
guess and i think
joe handled it well i thought his like
he's like i had no hard feelings to neil
young or joni mitchell like i'm still a
fan he told a story in his release about
how he like went to a neil young concert
as a kid um
so
buckle up i guess if we're cool enough
that'll happen to us you know what i'm
saying
well didn't we just talk about how
american boys and men are failing and
that's a problem we get canceled cancer
we'll get cancelled make more news
[Music]
you